hi this is kim from khan academy today
we're learning more about the seventh
amendment to the u.s constitution the
seventh amendment guarantees the right
to juries in civil cases
when the value and controversy is
greater than twenty dollars
to learn more about the seventh
amendment i talked with two experts
renee lerner is the donald philip
rothschild research professor of law at
george washington university law school
she specializes in u.s and english legal
history and she's written extensively
about the history of american juries
suja thomas is the peer and sarah
peterson professor of law at the
illinois college of law her research
interests include jury provisions in the
bill of rights civil procedure
and employment law
so professor thomas can you tell us a
little bit about why the framers were so
interested in protecting this right in
particular historically there were
juries in england and a lot of our
constitution
is based on
what occurred in in england
because of course that was our
historical origin and so colonists were
really familiar with juries and they
knew that the jury restrained government
and preserved liberty
and they also knew what could happen
without juries and so
because of this history
juries were really important to
americans and they put it in the
declaration of independence
and the framers in general
were very enthusiastic about juries one
of the reasons was that juries had been
important in helping to nullify british
laws that the american colonists didn't
like so an example of these laws is the
customs taxes these were taxes on
shipping and were very unpopular
especially in new england and what would
happen is merchants the boston merchants
were supposed to pay a customs tax on
merchandise that they imported into
boston and also in certain cases
exported what would happen is these
boston merchants would try to import
goods and not pay the tax
and sometimes they would get caught
by customs inspectors
if a customs inspector caught one of
these merchants trying to smuggle in uh
goods
the customs
collector would seize the ship and the
cargo and hold it essentially for ransom
the customs inspector would then bring
an action a lawsuit
against the ship and the cargo
in a court called the court of admiralty
which was a type of court that sat
without a jury and the judge
in the court of admiralty
would
ordinarily
require the merchant to pay a large fine
in order to get back his ship and his
cargo
so what the boston merchants started to
do they were deeply unhappy about these
fines they would bring a an action in a
court that sat with a jury it was an
action for trespass
against the customs inspector they knew
that juries could be really useful
because for example
there was concerns about
protecting litigants from bad laws um
also concerns about actions by the led
by the executive
and they were also concerned about
corrupt and biased judges so for all of
these reasons
there was a real value put on civil
juries
just for
our general information how exactly is a
civil trial different from a criminal
trial
there's when in a civil trial
someone is suing and wants
damages for something that went wrong so
if for example you're in an employment
situation and you allege your employer
discriminated against you
you can bring a civil case and
and you can and you can try to get
damages
or money
for the wrong that was committed against
you in that type of case people who are
trying to prove the case have to prove
by a preponderance of the evidence that
this is what happened to you that
discrimination occurred
then on in the criminal context on the
other hand someone is
accused of doing a crime
and um sometimes there's a grand jury
that decides whether that case should
proceed against you and then a criminal
jury decides um whether or not you
committed that crime and they have to
decide by
beyond a reasonable doubt and so the
standard is different it's for criminal
cases it's beyond a reasonable doubt
versus in a civil case by preponderance
of the evidence so it's it's a higher
standard to prove someone is guilty of a
crime than in a civil case to actually
win so you see this in the o.j simpson
case where
he's not convicted
but
they actually sued him in civil in a
civil case and they actually won and
there were different standards you kind
of see throughout
the
fourth through eighth amendments which
deal with the protection of the accused
quite an emphasis on juries so why were
the framers
so keen on juries
in the revolutionary era in particular
when tensions between the american
colonies and britain were very high
juries were one way
that americans could get popular
representation in government
they were not allowed to elect
members of the british parliament
they did
elect members of the
colonial legislatures but
increasingly
the british government was taking power
from the colonial legislatures
so this was a way
that
without an elected
legislature the colonists could get
representation
and john adams wrote a very interesting
passage in his diary in 1771
he wrote that juries were like popularly
elected legislatures that they serve
that function
in the american colonies
there were some concerns about
protection
for debtors and that was a big issue at
the time and there were arguments that
juries could really protect um litigants
from bad laws that the legislature
passed um from actions by the executive
and from
potentially corrupt and biased judges so
it wasn't the case that the the framers
believed that the jury was actually
perfect
but they thought that the jury was the
best decision maker
so it seems that the seventh amendment
has a very specific
origin in the history of the
revolutionary war and in some things
that were very dear to the founders what
are some of the ways that it has kind of
grown and changed in the years since
then
so there is
as you see in the
amendment a 20
amount in controversy requirement is
what we call it um
and that remains in force today
even though
there's been considerable inflation
and but still we've stuck with the 20
dollar
limit
the difficulty is today that very very
few cases go to juries and that is true
of the
federal courts and also the state courts
yeah that's one of the astounding things
that many people don't know about that
that less than one percent of civil
cases and we have the federal courts as
well as the state courts but in both of
those venues federal courts and state
courts less than one percent of civil
cases are tried by juries wow so what
happened there how did we get from a
point where the majority of the cases
went before a jury to less than one
percent
one thing that's affected how many cases
go to a jury
is that judges now have more power to
resolve disputes at an early stage
parties can file a motion to dismiss the
case
if they argue that the other side did
not have a claim
that would hold up under law judges can
dismiss a case
if they find that that's correct and
then around the 1930 period of time you
actually see all a number of decisions
against jury authority where the supreme
court actually had ruled in favor of
jury authority on this on the exact same
issue
and so something's going on in this time
frame around the 1930 period of time and
it's it's not exactly easy to figure out
what that is but some of the things that
i've seen in some of the public
documents that are out there you
actually see comments including by
a former supreme court justice saying
that you know judges are actually better
than juries um and and a new york state
judge
stated around this time yes a judge
should be preferred to a jury and so
that's certainly um part of what's going
on in the story and then part of what
was going on the story may be to do with
the
the jury is getting more diverse around
this period of time and
maybe there's an effort by other certain
parts of society to not want
diverse juries to decide their cases
so these are just a couple of different
ideas that i think are contributors to
why juries decide few cases today
interesting and so by this diversity do
you mean like diversity of people from
different classes or different genders
or different races what kind of
diversity is is entering in that time
period particularly we're talking about
um we'd be talking about uh sex and race
yeah yeah but i think class is
definitely you know part of that today
as well
and then another example that you know
is something that i've spent a good
amount of time in my career talking
about is something called summary
judgment and so summary judgment is a
procedure where a judge can decide what
a reasonable jury could find and if the
judge decides a reasonable jury could
not find for the person who brought the
case the judge can dismiss the case so
someone brings a case for employment
discrimination
and
there's discovery and that is you know
documents being exchanged between the
parties and depositions or questions
being asked between different witnesses
and so then an employer can say okay
you accused us of of employment
discrimination but we think you don't
have enough evidence and judge we think
that no reasonable jury could find for
this employee
you should order summary judgment for us
and throw this case out of court
and what has actually happened is in
over 70 percent of the cases where a
employer makes a motion for summary
judgment in an employment discrimination
case
that
case will be
dismissed
in whole or in part so judges can in
certain cases end the case before it
gets to a jury but by far the most
common way that a dispute ends is by
settlement between the parties what has
encouraged settlement is that it's much
more expensive to bring a case and go to
jury verdict today than it was back at
the time of the founding one of the
reasons it's so much more expensive is
that we now have a system of what we
call discovery that is the parties can
ask for information from each other
before the trial they can formally
question witnesses they can ask for
documents they can require
questions to be answered all of that
goes on before the trial
and that's expensive to do
and they want to save money they want to
save
money that's involved in
this pre-trial discovery and they want
to save money at the trial
and so they go ahead and they settle
the reason it's so important for the
parties to save money is that in our
system each side in a dispute in a case
has to pay its own legal fees even if
they win
and so the parties have an incentive to
settle the case
that way they save
expenses
and also they get a predictable result
many parties are afraid of going before
a jury because they don't know what the
result will be for all these reasons
settlement has become
very important much more so than it was
at the time of the founding
so we've learned that the seventh
amendment's protections for jury trials
in civil cases
derives from the context of the
revolutionary war
when colonists felt that juries were
perhaps the only way they could have a
voice in the law
despite this protection fewer than one
percent of civil cases go to trial today
since trials have become prohibitively
expensive and their outcomes are
unpredictable to learn more about the
seventh amendment visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics